hello commander in the light of the
recent extraterrestrial incursion this
Council of Nations has convened to
approve the activation of the XCOM
project you have been chosen to believe
this initiative to oversee our first and
last line of defense your efforts will
have considerable influence on this
planet's future
we urge you to keep that in mind as you
proceed
good luck commander hello and welcome to
the video this is the first video in my
playthrough of this game this is XCOM
enemy Unknown this is a game where acept
effectively we are saving the world
there is an alien menace which is
affecting the planet and it is up to us
and our crack team of soldiers to try
and stop it
I've actually skipped out a few of the
early things in the game just because I
thought you know I don't think that that
interesting to look at all those oh
they're holographic things okay whatever
so we're actually a little way into the
game we've got some research on the go
with building something with 31 days to
prove to our funding council that we are
good for something which hopefully we
will do that's exactly believe it or not
what we want to see okay so this is what
we have to choose we have to choose one
of these sites and they have different
bonuses so if we need engineer's to
build things for us we need scientists
to learn about those things before we
can build them and we also need cash
because we need to pay people I don't
think that's gonna be worth it 200 is
not all of that much I'd actually say
that scientists were probably the most
important so I think we're gonna go
there Edmonton Canada
this is our squat we have here you had
is Kepler we have Hypatia Archimedes of
Syracuse the game thinks a surname is
offs IRA keys and Caroline Herschel you
were not ready for you yet I don't want
you I want Copernicus yes Nicholas
Copernicus will be joining us this is
our squad we're going to be going
through basically the greatest
physicists and scientists and
mathematicians of all time and we're
gonna be entrusting them to save the
world or at least that's the idea that's
that
so for those of you that aren't familiar
with the game this is a turn-based
combat system will be a fighting an
alien menace and it is know so basically
we are now going to land and we're gonna
fan out and just try and identify I love
this this is like an alien and no alien
sign on the back of it thank you
right so we can't see very much the map
the thing about this game is it is quite
scary and it is very easy to get your
men killed so we're gonna try and not do
that I say men we do have Hypatia is
actually in command so there's a cover
system having said that it's very easy
to get yourself killed these shields
that half shield indicates I'm half in
cover if there's a full shield somewhere
which would be like if I was against
this wall then that means I'm completely
in cover and obviously that's a pretty
good thing the difficulty is we don't
know where our enemies are going to come
from I'm gonna guess that there's some
in there though but I'm gonna best fan
out and see if we can find anybody and
the way this works is you effects we
have two turns per character I just used
one turn by moving to there I could use
the second turn to move again but that
means I think can do anything and thing
with this game is you have to be very
tactical about where you move them and
where you put people because it's very
easy to someone just be left in the open
and if you're left in the open you will
die so you know bear that in mind okay
how much them I don't think this
Kentucky there's not gonna be anyone
from this way so let's make a panic us
up on the side
I might actually oh I don't like this
sir I forgot a scare this game was I
haven't I've never completed this game
before I've got a halfway through a
playthrough and then worst out so I'm
somewhat familiar with the controls but
it's been a little while what we're
gonna do then is for all of these people
second terms we're just gonna overwatch
so overwatch just means that they're
waiting for something they're waiting
for for an alien to a parent if it
appears you get a chance to shoot it
let's just see if that happens
uh I hope that wouldn't happen okay
Kepler so I have tried to make these
guys look as much like their historical
counterparts as possible but there's
obviously a little bit of in you know
interpretation going on this is an alien
pod and these are this is the grisly
after effect of the aliens they are
abducting people and that kind of
gossamer type stuff is what they're they
used to do that so trying to avoid that
fate for you Hanna's Kepler oh come on
please just spot somebody please please
please please please okay right let's go
here Archimedes is the oldest person on
the squad he was born in 287 BC and it's
pretty much when the greatest scientist
of all time it was great as a
mathematician of the classical era we
actually did a feature on him as we did
with the he of the people that were
going to be covering on the science hour
and I'm with Hypatia he's here these are
the two Ancients basically of the squad
I just love that it's soldier of
Syracuse which I suppose it's actually
slightly ironic because he was killed in
the siege of Syracuse when the Ravens
invaded he very much wasn't a soldier
okay so okay she's found something joy
right okay
Kepler are these people everyone in this
series is just so interesting my
everybody has a really interesting story
to tell us just a little bit annoying
that I can only tell them quite slowly
those are wrap right gone okay these are
the aliens these are sex toys which are
basically let your classic little green
men so we've got that to deal with
Archimedes has heard them and Hypatia
knows there's something over here so I'd
like to do where do they go they're ever
here won't they I quite like to take
them out I'm gonna leave Hypatia to
watch over the left-hand side I pointed
at the screen I don't know why because
you can't see it and we're gonna move
off saira Keys up right right there they
are so v 45% chance to hit you are safe
and cover there's no way they can get to
Kepler's so in that case is it worth
moving up
I just want to get you killed okay what
balls - I just apologize by the way I
will be swearing in this series because
partly this is a game and games make me
competitive but also it's quite a scary
game and I swear when I'm scared so I'm
sorry if that offends your sensibilities
right Copernicus I got to pick one
overwatch next turn you can flank
Hypatia here on overwatch lieutenant
Sarah Keys you're the only person that
can now do anything I would like you sir
let ring bottom let's be fair you are
like you know dude 2200 years old okay
so that's telling me that the other one
is behind that car what he's done is
he's used his turn to give extra life to
that guy okay right so Kepler's pinned
down Archimedes can we use you can we
get you up hmm we get you outside here
49% chance
let's go for it but just shoot that one
he didn't even shoot through that window
okay
all right Copernicus let's move you up
here so whilst Archimedes is not a very
good shot he's actually you could really
regard him as being the founder of
modern physics well we're not modern
physics but he was the first person to
start applying over uno he was one of
the first people to start applying maths
to physical situations so he in a way
was like the forerunner of all all the
physics which is just it's applying Matz
to real things
apparently gunfire it's not one of those
things go on oh come on can none of you
shoot right you're in cover just don't
die okay so he's being boosted again oh
I hoped you wouldn't do that
oh god that was lucky Archimedes could
have been very much toast because of
that right we don't have any medicates
over so if they die that's it which had
to rather avoid can we get you
Copernicus let's move you up oh great
we were just activated another one right
can we take ok hundred percent chance
take him out Copernicus yes first kill
ghost Nicholas Copernicus Nicholas
Copernicus now where was that other as
why over there and there was another
squad over there somewhere wasn't there
Hypatia I want you to move up oh we
might have just we just a crowed
everybody one great okay now Hypatia is
a veteran of our first mission which
means she's actually got a rather
special ability I can't fire because I
move Bulls right hunker down
yeah hunker down right so she's got
extra cover from that basically
Archimedes his hit was still alive thing
is right if he if this guy runs over
here you could flank either of these two
and I'm not sure I'm not gonna trust
Archimedes a sec another hit so I'm
gonna move you mmm I'm gonna be doing
that jump for the window right
Kepler
you've already moved it's just kept left
okay
if we could get on the roof that would
be great but I can't see any way of
doing that okay
not yet anyway we develop like ability
through this game one of them is the
ability to grapple on so things did you
have the right equipment okay so you
can't see anything either but let's put
you on overwatch so that will hopefully
pin this go down I see what he does
right that guy's subbing that guy okay
she's been shot at good at the start
this game you're so laughably outgunned
it's incredible ah rookie of Syracuse
was killed brilliant okay now what we
might be able to do those Avengers death
or the other Greek on the squad come on
yes
ah three kills for Hypatia so what
happened there was I shot a rocket which
is her a unique ability because she's
because she's gone free one mission
already
she's been promoted to a heavy and there
are first classes you can have and that
rocket killed these two aliens but it
also severed the connection that this
alien had but this one which killed it
so three kills in one she was also just
pretty badass I guess I had so much more
I wanted to talk about Archimedes I
guess I can't okay there's only 45
percent chance the Copernicus move you
up is that that's still within the first
turn isn't it right okay
it's possible today down suppressing
fire if one of the classes but it's not
this slide I think yes see inhale Thanks
it's probably what a lot of Catholics
thought about him at the time that's for
a future episode
okay Archimedes is dead that's David
it's not like I've done loads of
research on him or anything all right
no no let's move you back around here
okay
yeah our communities um so one of the
things I did at Oxford was actually did
a presentation on the history of pi is
something I'd still really like to do
for the YouTube channel
what's up was that car I think car just
drove past like with through all of this
carnage mental and one of the really
well the first big player in the history
of Pi it was um was Archimedes 27
percent chance let's see the second
chances
oh my god so there were what four alien
kills so six alien comes forward them
would you two Hypatia
that was amazing operations soaring
sensor
well one Sentinel has soared Archimedes
is no longer with us
yeah and he did this amazing methods to
estimate pike or the method of
exhaustion I will do a video about it in
the future but he was he was pretty
awesome
and dead what's the Kepler Ono cap that
didn't actually kill anyone he just drew
that fire okay lady Hypatia is just
wiping the floor with everybody okay so
Copernicus has got a very dangerous job
the assault class is the guy that
basically runs in kicks the door down
and shoots shotgun at whatever there is
in the room often you don't know what's
in the room until you kick the door down
so Copernicus is life expectancy is
rather slim so that's this ability now
basically you get promoted depending on
how well you do emissions so he's
already got one HP extra from that as
you progress you can choose you know one
promotion or another okay no one was
injured either which is what Archimedes
was added in a big way okay so we can
have a lab oh this lady
I heard you this lady gets on my tits so
much okay right so we've got more more
scientists but panics increased across
the areas that we didn't rescue
yep you're wrong when basically and we
are also in very deep trouble